this is poll driven i mean look this is
they always say trust the science but we
know what it's been it's been trust the
polls
trust the teachers union remember it was
just a few weeks into the administration
where we got the emails now where
dr malinsky was talking with the head of
the aft
about guidance for schools basically
taking what the teachers union said
versus what the doctors at cdc were
saying so this has always been all over
the place and driven by politics so
that's jim jordan from ohio but earlier
today republicans questioning the timing
the announcement many are calling the
move
long overdue in light of the science
which has not changed for months
from the white house with me now andy
slavitt senior advisor for the coba 19
response and sir thank you for your time
and
good morning to you thanks for having me
back bill
did you wear a mask this morning i did
not i did not
what changed well what changed is the
cdc over the last several weeks
uh gathered evidence which showed them
three things
one we have an exponential drop now in
cases
so it works the same way when it goes
down is when it goes up we've had a 30
30 drop in the last week or so uh
secondly
there is evidence that the vaccines work
at preventing the spread now which
many people suspected but they now have
some good data on including they've got
data that uh
that the vaccines are effective against
the variants which is i think a piece of
information they're waiting for
and finally every american now over 12
is eligible for the vaccine
so it's hard to uh and we have plenty of
vaccine supply so i think those three
factors together what the cdc explained
to us
was why they decided it was time to say
hey if you've been vaccinated
you no longer need to wear your mask you
give me a chance to challenge you on
that here
it was only 36 hours ago the head of the
cdc said no change and dr falchi pretty
much
said the same thing as well seven days
ago they were telling
12 year olds to wear a mask at summer
camp in july i mean that's
i mean that really is a swap admiral
brett jarrar he was sort of in your spot
you know for the last administration
part of operation warp speed
said this about 90 minutes ago
who knows what took the cdc so long this
probably could have been done about a
month ago
dr wolinski was absolutely intransient
in her position
yesterday morning dr fauci said yeah you
still need to wear a mask
indoors and even outdoors if you're in a
crowd and by the afternoon it was all
over
they probably got some political
direction and they made the change
i welcome the change we should all
welcome the change it's supported by the
science it's a good thing for our
country uh agreed it's a good thing for
the country just respond to some of the
allegations he's laying down there in
that comment
well look the cdc guidance is going to
be what it is until it changes there's
no in-between guidance
we didn't find out at the white house
until 9 00 pm the night before
that the cdc was just was going to make
this change yesterday
you know if they wanted to do this
politically conveniently wouldn't she
have done this before the hearing so she
didn't have to take
the tough questions rather than after
look she she's not running a popularity
contest and the cdc is always
going to be criticized as being either
too fast or too slow usually at the same
time by the way
they're getting it from both sides today
they got it from both sides before they
made this change
but their job isn't to be popular they
try to follow the science
our job at the white house is just to
let them follow the science and take
what comes
and try to explain it as best we can to
the american public i know it's a shock
to people
some will say it should have been done
long ago others are telling us
they're not quite sure how to adjust to
it uh but the bottom line is
they found evidence which tells them
that you don't need to wear a mask
if you're vaccinated and if you are
you're still in danger and you should
wear them out okay
two more things have you spoken with
wolinski from the cdc
well she and i did a press conference
yesterday afternoon
um i think it was yesterday um after uh
after the decision to to talk it through
to the public you did you did you did
press conference on thursday
that happened yes okay um you did
there are these there's the states
reviewing the guidance
but not yet following it or implementing
it is the word we're going to use here
a lot of these are blue states i mean
what do you say to the governors
what do you say to the mayors that are
making policy in those states
well i think you say two things first of
all you say this is what the science
says
so if the science tells us that uh
people who've been vaccinated
uh plus two weeks are safe you have to
tell the public what the science says
now the second question is guidance what
does everybody do what does every state
do what does every employer do
what do we as individuals do those
decisions are up to us
and they're up to businesses and they're
up to states the cdc is going to go
through
all of its guidance now summer camps
businesses travel etc
and over the next period of time i mean
they have thousands of pieces of
guidance out
they will update all of their guidance
but they wanted to put the conclusion
out there
recognizing that they're going to have
to update the rest of their guidance
but they felt it was fair to the
american public to say hey you know if
you've been vaccinated
you don't need to wear a mask it's a
remarkable turnaround in 47 days when
you go from impending doom
and the comments saying that you're
scared uh to this
so let's hope it sticks let's don't go
backwards
thank you for your time today